in this video we'll show you how to
detect anomalies
using streaming analytics and ai my name
is anagadiwanji
and my colleague preena bellara and i
are solution engineers for google cloud
many companies are dealing with the
proliferation of data
and difficulty in making sense of that
data at the speed required to make it
useful
this solution aims at sifting through
the mass of data to the events that need
additional attention
those outliers that indicate that
something is not going
as expected now what is anomaly
detection
spotting the unusual catching fraud and
discovering strange activity
all of this sounds like sherlock holmes
solving a mystery
that's what anomaly detection is except
we may not have a clear suspect to
search for
and you may not even know what the crime
is
when you see this example do you spot
any anomalies
first thought it's fairly easy to see
the large spike appears to be
an outlier but what if you have a large
sample of data
now the perception changes and what
appears to be an anomaly
turns out to be part of a regular and
familiar pattern
in this the anomalous behavior is not
the fact that there are spikes
but the observation that their frequency
fluctuates during an episode
the highlighted region denotes an
anomaly because the same low value
exists for an abnormally long time
anomalies are not defined by their own
characteristics but
in contrast to what is normal the speed
with which businesses are able to
identify anomalies
impacts their options for response for
example
not detecting a fraudulent financial
transaction immediately
and instead waiting hours or even days
often results in writing off the
financial loss
on the other hand finding the anomalous
transaction in seconds
allows for the invalidation of the
transaction and corrective actions to
prevent future fraud
similarly by detecting anomalies in
industrial equipment
manufacturers can predict and prevent
catastrophic failures
that could cause capital and human loss
by initiating proactive equipment
shutdown
and preventative maintenance likewise
for retail
we can see this being used to help
manage inventory
detect fraud and track user behavior
patterns
another example of an industry
application is a telco company doing
subscriber analytics
and specifically focusing on detecting
anonymous wireless traffic
real-time fraud detection on call and
sim
and user behavior pattern and across all
these industries
cyber security is top of mind for most
customers
because of economic costs of intrusion
and security attacks
let's talk about how to design a system
for intrusion detection
let's deep dive into our story for today
in our story we have stacy who's a data
analyst
her main role is to manage and monitor
the network for a large corporation
she needs to ensure everything is
running smoothly and if there's an
outage or unusual behavior
she needs to report it and take
corrective action
stacy's company currently has a hard
time anticipating network traffic
changes
which creates impediments in identifying
cyber security attacks they want to
catch unusual behavior and security
attacks
in real time and take action
leveraging google cloud streaming
service stacy can monitor the network
analyze the traffic and now has
opportunity to review and take action
such as file a ticket in near real time
when anomalies are found the solution
automatically sends an alert to stacy
and updates network health dashboards
now let's see an overview of how stacy
implemented
anomaly detection in google cloud
environment
there's four major components to this
ingest
extract and train predict and alert the
first step is ingesting unlabeled
streaming data
from all the sources google cloud pub
sub and google cloud storage make it
easy to ingest streaming data
next we transform and store this data in
google bigquery
extract features using data flow and
train the model with just some sql
after training this data we use data
flow to allow for online real-time
reporting and highlighting outliers
but it isn't just enough to detect
anomalies and monitor this data
the key is the action we take bi tools
such as tableau and looker
allow you to not only view this
information but take appropriate action
such as informing the security team
this was just a brief overview now let's
take a closer look
at each of these four components my
colleague preena balara will take it
forward
let's assume i'm stacy an analyst
task with soldiers business problem we
discussed earlier
first i look into the github repository
to understand
all of the four steps mentioned earlier
the first step you might recall
will be to ingest the data google
cloud's pub sub topic
can help us with the streaming ingestion
in order to do so
we also need to stimulate production
data to train our model
the photo on the right
shows the schema for the model
which resembles a nephroschema
we notice about 250 000 events per
second
in my production environment which comes
up to about 20 terabytes of data
from heterogeneous sources coming
through a pub sub topic
some of which will be labeled some may
be unlabeled
let's look at the next step now that
we've set up the ingestion
the next question is how do we ensure
the solution is scalable
if you recall we were generating or
anticipating 250 000 events
per second we need to aggregate this
data
this ties to the second step which is
extract entry
using data flow beam and its p pre-built
transform such as
minimum maximum and count we can ingest
and aggregate these logs or events
thereby reducing the number of elements
or the amount
volume of elements from 11 gigabytes to
1.03 gigabytes
as you can see additionally data flow
beam allows us to auto scale thereby
generating or helping us build a
pipeline that is production ready
we will use dqml's key means clustering
model
to train this extracted data we've
decided to use k-means as a
since it's a common algorithm used for
unsupervised machine learning as you can
see i wrote the sql query
to create a model run the command and in
15 minutes
we have a model configuration is easy
simply mention the columns i wanted as
features and set the number of clusters
this is great because machine learning
requires some trial and error and the
quick turnaround time helps me to play
with the configuration
and determine the most optimum
combination for my use case
another great feature for an analyst is
the scheduled query
i don't want to just create a model one
time and leave it i want it to learn
continuously and be updated with the
latest patterns
using a scheduled query and a stored
procedure i can rerun this query in a
timely manner
thereby keeping my model updated
additionally once the model is created
we will calculate the normalized
distance for each centroid or grouping
to determine if the input that we
received is
too far from the cluster thereby dealing
it as an
outlier
now that the model is ready it's time to
detect outliers
how do we do this the answer is data
flow we pass the normalized data in the
pipeline as an input
and we use this data to calculate how
far our input data is from the centroid
it needs our distance threshold
we don't store them as an output uh if
we store them as an outlier in the
bigquery table
the result we are now notified of the
outlier and can provide
little to no downtime
now that we have enabled real-time
detection it's time to view our results
and most importantly take appropriate
action
we will leverage google's looker
dashboard to do this
let's take a look as you can see
in this locker dashboard i can see the
number of events
the sort whether it was an anomaly as
well as
the bytes there is another column over
here called actions which allows me to
take appropriate action
i can either create a jira ticket texas
security consultant or email the
security team
thereby notifying my team of the right
action
you can also use any other third-party
tool
that is supported by google cloud for
your reporting needs
in summary we've built this in a short
time processed over 250 000 events
using data flow we can consume all of
this
20 terabytes of daily data from various
sources
we trained and evaluated on one terabyte
data in 15 minutes using sql
we found outliers in near real time and
took appropriate action
we've covered a lot of ground for more
implement
for more information on how to implement
this in your environment please check
out the github link